[Applause]
i just love these two of course that's
blake shelton and gwen stefani's latest
duet happy anywhere
featured on his brand new album body
language but nearly six years ago
the pair wrote their first song together
go ahead and break my heart
when they started seeing each other in
the midst of their divorces
and in a new interview with apple
music's zayn low blake looks back on
working with his now fiance and admits
there was a time they wondered if their
relationship was
just a rebound we were just starting
to see each other and and we were both
going through
horrible breakups divorces
and horrible in that it was just sad
you know yeah and and so
i there was times where gwen and i would
be like
you know are we is this are we
rebounding here
is that what we're doing together
because this makes no sense right
and and so that we would always have
these conversations of like oh yeah this
we're just you know we're just getting
over you know our
our crap with each other you know well
of course we all know it clearly wasn't
a rebound of course blake finally popped
the question to gwen back in 2020
sharing the news to his 4 million
followers on instagram
writing hey gwen stefani thanks for
saving my 2020
and the rest of my life i love you i
heard a yes
and after nearly six years together and
four musical collaborations
blake's clearly still in awe to work
with the former no doubt lead singer
but it really like was a shocker to me
that
oh my god i'm writing a song with gwen
stefani like
all but that not only only then that it
kind of hit me like
she's an incredible songwriter these
things she's coming
and then her voice on the on the voice
notes the way she sounded just singing
it like a little scratch vocal to show
me what she was thinking it's like
that voice like you talk to her and she
talks she sounds like gwen but when she
sings
all of a sudden it's it's the girl it's
don't speak
it's it's yeah you know what i mean it's
that
it's that icon it's icon status you know
so i still
to answer your question i think i'm i'm
still not really over that hump
and i'm still more in kind of blown away
fan
shocked mode when i when i actually work
with her
honestly we don't blame you blake gwen
has surprised audiences at many of his
concerts and the gods country singer
says he feels like a kid on christmas
morning every time she comes out on
stage
we'll have a plan that she's at one of
my concerts
and and we always try to keep it on the
down low
uh and then we'll start nobody but you
and and or go ahead and break my heart
and then
i'll be singing it and here i am dying
from the time i stand on stage
walk out on stage till that moment hits
because i know on that set list
people are going to sh in their seats
when they when gwen stefani walks out
here it's like i'm still like a kid on
christmas morning
and so that's what it's like for me
working with her it's just
it's just exciting it really is